Jason is in San Antonio hey Jason how
are you doing good how are you sir
better than I deserve what is your net
worth sir two million dollars two
million dollars very cool and what is
that invested in it is first Savings
Plan and mutual funds and Roth IRA okay
house in there yeah we have a house
that's worth four hundred about okay so
four hundred of its a house the rest of
its and mutual funds and retirement
plans good how old are you exactly
fifty-one you're a young millionaire how
much of this money did you inherit well
when they my mom and dad passed away I
inherited four hundred thousand but that
was about a year ago okay so you're
already a millionaire before that
happened exactly okay and your range of
income through your working life sir
well household household in between
household income you're just gonna owe
between thirty starting out and then as
I ended it up he was 130 okay very cool
all right and what you do for a living
what was your career I was in the
military for 31 years
okay well thank you for your service and
what was your highest rank Oh lieutenant
girl okay Wow
Wow very cool and did your wife work
outside the home oh she stayed at home I
was the one who worked and now I
volunteer outside the home but limited
when I want to yeah sure okay do you
have a college degree yes I've got a
bachelor's and a master's okay in what
ones an agriculture and the others and
entomology Public Health okay oh and
your GPA you're breaking up you there
yeah okay you're breaking out here
barely oh no now I can yes yeah the
bachelors of about a 3.5 and the Masters
was about a 3.3 okay cool
how much of the two million dollar net
worth is there because you borrowed
money to invest and make money I'd say
maybe a hundred ninety I two hundred
because what we did as we've moved
around the United States we would you
know buy our house that we lived in and
then we would rent it out when we left
so maybe the equity of the real estate
that we were in it out was maybe one to
two hundred thousand five gotcha okay
what part has giving played in your
financial plan through the years well
we've given to the church we give to
veterans organization and also people
that we know they're in need okay what's
the most expensive pair of jeans you
ever bought Oh about thirty forty bucks
you know a pair I mean he'll I mean if
he saw me you wouldn't know I mean I was
like a slob anyway so okay so how many
brand-new cars did you buy before you
had at least a 1 million dollar net
worth oh when I was 18 when I got a
basic training I bought a brand-new car
but after that that was it but with that
brand new car that I bought I ran it to
300,000 miles Wow okay very cool very
cool
so what you obviously did this with a
military career very very impressive the
TSP has been very good to you the Thrift
Savings Plan and so what is your advice
to the military family that's out there
listening right now that's 25 years old
can they still become a millionaire in
America oh just max out your Roth IRA
with gross mutual funds and then max out
your thrift savings plan
they just live you know live below your
means even if you can't max it out but
what you can in there and just stay the
course pretty much that's little
happened so you haven't borrowed money
to create any of this and more money
didn't cause this to happen
it was just steady steady steady
investing yeah steady investing that you
know I started that probably around 1988
and then they just grew over time and
sort of didn't I didn't really know it
until you know made
about you know after I came back from
Afghanistan wow look at all this hit my
20 year mark I said good you know hey I
can now go ahead and hang it up if I
want any time hmm Wow well way to go sir
you're a hero for serving your country
and an economic hero for achieving a two
million dollar net worth very proud to
talk to you Jason thank you for calling
in hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a $500,000